glenda vega my life wouldn't be the same
she gave me the strength and courage to
go
to washington dc on february 11th at the
warner theater and do stand-up comedy
i'll be at christy comedy.com february
11th warner theatre washington dc and
then the very next night february 12th
the tabernacle atlanta georgia for
homeless pimp's birthday show february
12th beautiful and i'm going to dc she
gave me that strength but she gave me
this trend to go to dc on february 19th
and there i'm playing the
capital one hall the night before that
i'm in albany playing the egg on
february 18th i mean the egg is the best
and we sold out the first one trying to
sell out the second egg because who
orders one egg nobody orders one egg you
gotta have eggs you gotta break couple
eggs and make an omelette february 26th
i will be at the borgata in atlantic
city that show was rescheduled because
of the snowstorm march 4th i will be in
royal oak michigan at the royal oak
music theater and march 5th agora
theater cleveland ohio i just played the
agora it was a hot show i loved it
you're going to love it there really
playing the royal oak theater when march
4th i'm playing it february 11th uh
unless it happened already no it's
happening this coming week yes february
11th at the royal oak and uh right
outside detroit february 12th at
pittsburgh
in the freaking i can't i don't remember
the music
homestead steakhouse there's second
shows in all these places that's what
we're trying to sell out get this
avocado company.com listen to this babe
and then also we got a documentary
coming out on
youtube.compresh that homeless pimp uh
film the documentary of taste buds and
hey bait behind the scenes stuff it's
gonna be touring behind the scenes
everything it's a fully real life like
it's a two-hour job
also like and subscribe to our youtube
page okay you need to like subscribe to
spotify
leave us a rating give us a follow eat
the [ __ ] out of you yeah it means us we
never ask we never ask for anything but
it means a lot ask if you want to get
the absolute [ __ ] kicked out of you yeah
if you do
then you won't like it subscribe to the
podcast correct if you don't then like
and subscribe me and chris you're at the
ryman march 11th
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe
[Music]
and i don't wanna go crazy
but every thug needs a hey baby yeah
yeah what's that babe how you doing i'm
doing all right
good i um yeah man what do you think of
a guy with an eye patch does that scare
you more than a guy with cauliflower ear
who scares you more eye patch guy or
cauliflower cauliflower your guy i'll
tell you why that's
a telltale sign of that you're that
you're a professional fighter or you get
you're taking
repeated beatings you don't get
cauliflower here because you were in a
few scraps in the alleyway you know
after school after three o'clock but if
you have an eye patch nah that could be
an accident
but look at the guy look at the senator
or whatever the guy the guy with the eye
patch oh well he was in the wall but
like
yeah
yeah but i can get poked in the eye and
wear an eye patch right i'm not going to
get cauliflower yeah i will not let
myself get hit that what about this one
i will run you ready for this yeah who
would you rather fight you have to fight
one of them guy with cauliflower you're
a guy with rabies who do you fight
cauliflower
sober
full guy full on rabies
uh i fight the guy with rabies i'll tell
you why okay one he's got to break skin
two there's a tetanus shot
i don't know if i walk away from the guy
who has cauliflower here i think before
i'm done he's got me in in a real naked
joke
one more question please we'd rather
fight a guy with cauliflower ear or an
animal with rabies
oh
see i still go animal interesting let a
raccoon bite me i'll just run to see the
sinai so the cauliflower ear guy scares
you
more than anybody yeah it does
interesting
one more
please what about a cauliflower ear
woman
fighting her
i'm not fighting her you're not fighting
her i'm not fighting her either
interesting no because what am i gonna
do there's no wind there for me yeah i
beat her i beat a woman she beats me the
woman beat me up there's no wind you
just walk away there's no wind i'll tell
you i'll i'll engage with a cauliflower
pizza if i have one delicious i like
cauliflower pizza better than regular
pizza cauliflower
how did cauliflower invade and become
different forms all of a sudden i'll be
eating anything they'll be like you like
that it's made of cauliflower i'm like
how how is it made of coffee i don't
understand how vegan restaurants how
they're like it's a philly cheese stick
i'm like yeah but how they're like oh
it's saitan i'm like what yeah saitan i
don't know it's not a philly cheesesteak
it's their best attempt at flavors that
can come close to a philly cheese some
of it actually tastes like a philly
cheesesteak really yeah there's a vegan
restaurant um down in the city on like
uh avenue a in manhattan that it's a
vegan place they have philly
cheesesteaks you would never know the
diff i mean you would know the diff but
i like that because if i did would you
ever consider going vegan and see what
it does to you yeah well i'm not
drinking until my birthday maybe i'll go
vegan tulum maybe i'll go vegan tola
july 4th going vegan i think going vegan
is harder than you think like the second
you leave here when you're about to eat
you got to educate yourself on what is
vegan and then you also don't have
access to all vegan all the time so i
think you have to like
learn it that it's a learned lifestyle
like i'm gonna have stuffed peppers for
dinner tonight but if i just don't put
the meat in it's veg
i guess but now i'll open up a cheese
but now what are you gonna you can't
well you could put nutritional yeast
that's nice make yourself some pepsi
nutritional yeast yeah and until july
4th and then uh
you're not just gonna eat you're not
just gonna eat peppers in your
nutritional yeast for dinner
right
i mean pimp doesn't pimp's vegan are you
vegan for the most part no except beer
and cheese it's not chicken yeah but
that's the only thing yeah it's just a
bunch of vegetables i always feel like i
don't know chicken's trying to disgust
me i
[Music]
know on the bone like poultry chicken
starting to make it's starting to feel
like gross yeah i don't know what it is
my head is turning on chicken i'm like i
don't want to eat a bird like cow isn't
as nasty as chicken because you see how
inhumanely they're treated i'm like it's
gross it's gross i don't want to eat
that and i almost often feel now
chickens i get i get i get two i get in
my head when i eat it's gummy it's gummy
it's chewy it's stringy sometimes it's
pink or it has like a little red streak
getting in and they're always like no
that's just i'm like i don't know about
that yeah i don't like it you know what
i had to i bet i'm huge on fish i know
that you watch a show like see spirit
see and they say fishes plastics and
blah blah blah
it doesn't bother me fish i could eat a
fish alive i can eat i'll eat goldfish
right out of the bowl
i don't see i don't i don't believe i'm
gonna say this right now and you can
clip this i don't think fish have
feelings i don't care about fish i
there's for human consumption only i'll
eat i'll eat i can't agree
i can't agree with you who says they
don't feel pain who says that they don't
remember after three seconds how do we
know that how do we know that because
you know what i think it is with the
fish here's what i'm saying with the
fish is because they're not even like
they they can live underwater i have
nothing in common with them yeah i can't
even hold my breath for 10 seconds yeah
but that's not think about that as a uh
that statement even more broad i don't
know those people that don't live near
me i have nothing come with that how do
you know how do you know cauliflower
doesn't feel pain after three seconds
how do you know it doesn't have a
central nervous system but that but so
maybe they're so advanced that they
could still feel pain without a central
nervous system you've never been able to
talk to a cauliflower i look real good
today i don't look so good today i don't
know i don't know but i'm i feel really
bad for fish i mean i ate them i ate
everything you know i wasn't sharing for
seven years we talked about that but the
fact that you did that yeah is just
it really is when you said that to us
me and pimp still sometimes talk about
it when he's
no he's in my freezer right now is he
still back in there he's in there yeah
but okay so let's get into this so i
take back what i said about fish i was
just trying to be dramatic
yeah we're doing things
i don't hate fish but i do like i will
eat them more than any other animal you
ever cook a lobster and i feel bad you
just drop it in the pot or some people
take that like the metal thing and just
stick it right through them and they
like screech but apparently it's just
air
yeah it's terrible it's terrible
is there something why can't they just
kill the lobster first
like why do you have to put it in the
pot alive unclear does anybody i i heard
about something about freshness but
can't you just like can't you just hit
it over there with a mallet right right
right can't you just inject it with you
know whatever they kill prisoners yeah
really just give it the electric chair
we cook lobsters live to minimize
getting sick from them what
the flesh of lobsters crabs and other
shellfish is full of bacteria that can
be harmful to humans if ingested cooking
shellfish alive reduces the chances of
vibriosis causing bacteria ending up on
your plate what well then they got to be
cooked alive i don't know what to tell
you
lobsters another shellfish have harmful
bacteria naturally present in their
flesh once the lobster is dead the
bacteria can rapidly multiply and
release toxins that may not be destroyed
via cooking you therefore minimize the
chance of food poisoning by cooking the
lobster alive so what about when you buy
frozen foods
frozen lobster frozen shrimp and all
that [ __ ] but it's dead already right
that's what i'm saying but
they kill it and then they freeze it or
they just freeze it alive oh did they
freeze it alive can you eat frozen
lobster
what do you mean like when you go get a
popsicle from a store i'm saying you go
get a lobster from the fish market they
give you a live lobster they give you a
dead lobster
well usually they give you a lot it's a
live lobster you get out of the tank
have you ever cooked lobster at home i i
have i have been amongst people cooking
in the house and they brought live
lobsters into the house live
and they throw it right into the pot
yeah
actually did it this year casey joe's
cooked them
and he just you just fill up a possible
water life or somebody threw it in the i
had reservation we went to the store we
bought them right and then we went back
and we just they were on the table so he
brought it home it was rolling around i
had no idea what was going on yeah i
thought it was going for a ride maybe
got a new owner and then you boiled it
alive yeah
i know it feels better i feel like and
people that anybody that says salvation
is a good person you're wrong
i love chris thinks the lobsters
lobsters believe they're being adopted
i'm just like finally i gotta know you
saying goodbye to all it's lobster
friends
i've been chosen
same thing with crabs you gotta throw
crab right in the pot alive um i think
krabs going alive too yeah yeah well but
it's interesting why it only happens
with lobsters and shellfish they release
the bacteria like you don't have to kill
anything else alive and eat it right
away yeah it's strange maybe that's why
too
you know like unfortunately like in in
some countries they eat dog they say
they they they burn them
alive they burn them death alive because
there's more flavor in the meat
that's you can't deal with but what's
there between that and a lobster really
they i know the central nervous system
in the brain i know we've only only
domesticated them and so we feel like
that's okay right but if we domesticated
cows right you know what i mean like
like i watched a documentary once that
said the beef and dairy industry picked
the animals that we eat it's it's
cheaper
and and more cost
friendly for cows to drink their milk
and eat their meat if it was more cost
friendly to eat um you know lamb meat
and drink lamb milk we would do that but
it's not so it's like you look at or
horses you look at a horse
you just get trained to like what
in what way shape or form with the great
creators whoever created us why would we
drink cow's milk right it has nothing to
do with our our body at all right but
we've just been screwed into our head
you need cows calcium milk but yeah it's
just because it's cost friendly if it
was if it was friendly to drink some
other type of animal milk then we'd say
you'd be like move [ __ ] get out the way
yes exactly drink pig milk yeah it was
chewy it's chewy and fatty what is this
oh what a dog meat it's chewy and fatty
with strong animal taste like squab or
venison what squash
but not as succulent
they the minced galang galangal and
subtle charcoal flavor were pleasant
enough and the meat itself was
reminiscent of beef if you close your
eyes you didn't think about it too much
that's that's what you want in a meal
just close your eyes and make believe
it's something else yeah yeah
yeah but they're intelligent beings it's
veal is another thing that's horrible
that's bad i don't know
allegedly they say baby cows they never
let their feet reveal that their feet
never hit the floor
that's what they say what's the food
where they they put the tube down the
like duck's throat and then just fill it
with fat until it dies
oh fog fog
fog is another horrible thing
yeah google fog spelled f a
no he's ready
f o
e f-o-i-e-g-r-a-s fog
f-o-i-e-g-r-a-s let's see how close i've
seen it what did i nail it yeah there
you go i had my eyes raw i thought it
was didn't i thought it was i thought it
was frog's legs no specialty food made
of the liver of a duck or a goose yeah
fog was defined as a liver of a duck
who's fattened by garvage force-feeding
yeah i've had foie gras
ravioli did you at uh
scarpetta i believe it was or something
like that was it very good it was very
good but i know you were eating fat a a
duck that got real fat i only knew i
feel like fog right now it was it was in
the uh it was in the in the ravioli and
it was very very tasty i didn't eat it
just like that though you could put
anything in the ravioli oh no yeah
that's what they do and then no does it
die from getting filled up with fat yeah
it dies from being like drowning in fat
no
very nice oh my god i had no idea that's
the first last time i'll eat that oh
that's terrible oh my god it's terrible
yeah they killed it forced feeding it
corn
oh my god they take it to live around
that that's the worst way to die that's
the worst why why
oh that's horrific yeah i don't like
that i don't hate corn do you like corn
i don't need corn i i don't i eat corn i
don't like corn you know what i'm
realizing i don't like anymore tomatoes
really i'm more
tomato sauce but an actual tomato a bed
a tomato like tomatoes could be [ __ ] a
sliced tomato it's like you know what i
don't need i don't like it yeah i just
i'm not into it tomato sauce you know i
can't do without but that's disgusting
see you don't know what you don't know
what you're really how are they allowed
to do that how are they allowed to put a
tube in a duck and just blow it up like
it's about hurt any rules in france they
don't live by the rules really you can't
you could have an affair on your spouse
they don't care as long as you don't
fall in love you can openly have sex
outside your marriage you don't get in
trouble not true that's not their
culture
swear to god google are you allowed to
cheat on your spouse in french law
you're just not allowed to fall in love
but they believe sex is a physical thing
how could they put that into the
crossfit in french law yeah how did they
prove you fell in love with someone or
just slept with them it's okay to
publicly promote infidelity don't matter
you can go you can go to publicly
promote it okay
can you cheat on your wife in france
yeah have a very free mind and
can consider it cheating is not a moral
issue
dating is different in france there's
not a protocol like there is in some
other countries dating needs exclusivity
you don't go out with different men and
women so in other words you could fall
in love with a woman or a man
and then you're done then you're getting
divorced but if you just have sex with a
man or a woman on a business trip or
something like that you just want to get
funky after ramada you don't get in
trouble for that it's like it's like you
know forgetting to take out the trash
like honey
you know come on but then vice verse
yeah but they don't because they don't
view sex as as like um it you can't fall
in love that's the cardinal sin they're
all about love this is crazy i didn't
know like you could actually face jail
time for cheating on someone in in the
u.s adultery isn't just a crime in the
eyes of your spouse and 21 states
cheating in a marriage is against the
law punishable by fine fire even jail
states with anti-cheating laws generally
define adultery as a married person
having sexual intercourse with someone
other than their spouse how could they
how could they
how could they put government into a
relationship that's insane this is a new
thing with the government in the
relationship this uh 200 years ago
oh by the way speaking of just just
something about history have you ever
seen the picture of abraham lincoln on
his deathbed that is just coming to the
surface now no google abraham lincoln
death photo it's eerie i watched a whole
special on it called lost lincoln on
discovery plus which is going to be
getting rid of a show called the taste
buds very soon right
um discovery plus this apparently
there's a
show called coming out called the taste
buds
about two two buddies that talk about
food on the discovery channel so we have
to look into that yeah and if you need a
good recommendation for a lawyer i got
one because i'm in three active lawsuits
oh my god is that real so
some people are saying the internet's
saying it's not but they're saying that
it is because if you look if you make
that one big pimp if you can see his
right eyes bulging out that's where he
was shot his his eye is bulging out of
his head this is allegedly lincoln like
oh he died like minutes before this we
could take photos of that then that this
guy did and it was like what years what
year did he get 1865 april of 18th or
january of 1865 or april of 1865 um what
year was the photograph invented
uh uh like 1860
i'm going to course 1858
is when it was photographed or maybe not
um cameras created in the 1800s so yeah
so so they're saying that that picture
if you
uh if you google uh that yes
that this was president lincoln on his
deathbed now i don't know to the naked
eye it like it looks like it could be
him yeah i don't know in this day and
age
with with how do you prove anything with
i mean with the deep fakes and all the
photoshops well they're saying that the
in the documentary the lost lincoln they
said that it was hands because they were
matching facial bones and scars that
they did like deep you know dives on the
photo can you make that bigger pimp that
is wild pig can make anything bigger
yeah
wow that's crazy dude
that's what it is yeah the lost lincoln
where'd you watch that i watched on
discovery plus oh that is we're mad at
them right now eerie yeah it's eerie
right like it's just like that's what
they're but again it doesn't look
exactly like him but have the same beard
i mean i could go take this shot in
crown heights any any second of the day
and just make it look exactly like that
but they authenticated it saying that
it's actually from that time and that
they think that it's him but i i don't
know so they took a photo of him right
after he died yes they couldn't even
photograph him alive
yeah i don't know i i don't know like
what the actual story is because he's
feeling this close i had to make delilah
cereal and i missed some key parts she
just would not stop yelling at me to
give her cereal and i just was like fine
so yeah so but then they said that when
he actually died they
stripped his body down nude and they
wrapped it in american flag that's what
they said all right
i don't know if you guys want that to
happen like if i came and found you dead
would you want me to strip you naked
wrap your merch i'd romp you i want you
to wrap me in a handbag merch yeah
yeah
yeah no i i you know it's interesting
what they do like
i get that but like you know you ever
heard like like bin laden like they
buried him at sea and it's a little like
weird why they do that like why did you
have to throw him in the ocean they
buried him at sea they just threw his
body into the ocean but it's like isn't
it wouldn't you like be parading like
because now there's all this conspiracy
he's like did you really kill him why'd
you throw his body in the middle of the
ocean
it's weird right
is anyone allowed to do that
are you allowed to be like i want to be
very difficult to do that
right
no no
i think you should leave i think you're
like what is that can you do that the
hot dogs
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that i think you should leave sketch uh
sketch on netflix is the funniest thing
i've ever made funniest thing um the
moment we've been waiting for since
september okay we've been right all
right we're here we're in super bowl
season we are we're in super it's super
bowl 56
and draftkings uh sports book has a
special deal for our listeners and it's
pretty damn good we mentioned it before
uh i might have mentioned last week
they're giving new customers 56 because
the super bowl 56 yes so one oz uh for
either team you bet five bucks and you
win you get 280 80 in free bets and
guess what now it's in new york live
from new york it's draftking sportsbook
that's right
yeah and if it is in your state you can
still play draftkings daily fantasy
football contest for super bowl 56. but
we suggest if it isn't in your state to
move to that state that has it that's
correct that's what you need to do
because if you're not living if what's
the point of living in content of the
united states if your state doesn't have
draftkings i mean it's the best i
downloaded draftkings two football
seasons ago and every single sunday i
just make side bets because it makes my
watching more fun i don't bet a ton i'm
not a big big gambler yeah i put in
initially like a couple of hundred bucks
and i'm still playing off that money two
years listen i love it so much and i
literally i won't even take calls i
won't even talk to people i'm more of a
draft tyrant because i literally i can't
stop using this app and guess what if
you bet just five dollars and get 280 in
free bets if your team wins i'm sorry if
you download the draftking sports book
app use promo code hey babe and get 56
to one odds on either team 56 to one
odds and if you bet just five dollars
you'll get 280 in free bets if your team
wins that's promo code hey babe at
draftking sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of super bowl 56. now
bear with bear with i have some extra
information to give you yeah 21st as you
can see 21 years old or older minimum
age and location requirements vary by
jurisdiction c draftkings.com sportsbook
the full list of requirements for state
specific and responsible gaming
resources void we're prohibited gaming
problem call 100 gambler in tennessee or
call or text tn redline 1-800-889-9789
in connecticut call
seven seven eight hope 888-789-7777 or
tex hope ny four six seven three six
nine
twenty two seconds
raw
this podcast is sponsored by better help
listen better help's gonna assess your
needs and match it with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating under 48 hours
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide listen
we all have mental health issues these
days
go talk to somebody okay i've been
talking to somebody from betterhelp and
it's helped me frickin immensely okay
you can log into your account at any
time and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a weekly video or phone session
with the counselor and it's just the
best thing to do do you ever go on
better help i have it's not a crisis
line it's not self-help it's just
professional counseling done securely uh
i i wanted to see what it was all about
when we first started with them so i did
and i will tell you also um
a lot of people don't know where to get
help yeah they don't and it's just
incidentally if people are hearing this
and they've been thinking about it but
they didn't know where to go or not go
give it a whirl i mean what can it hurt
and all you got to do and if you go to
betterhelp.com hey babe that's
betterhelp.com hey babe you're going to
get 10 of your first month at
betterhelp.com hey babe that's a nice
little discount so i would do it and
they're recruiting additional councils
in all 50 states if you want to be on
the helping side that's right there you
go
wait what do you want to say you ever
think about so you could you could be
like bury me at c and then someone just
gotta throw you overboard and then you
drop to the bottom and then what whoever
eats you eats you i guess you're like a
buried treasure that's a good question
that's a good thing because i understand
you could be you know buried in a
cemetery or cremated but could i be
requested to be buried at sea i know you
could be cremated and then have your
ashes scattered over something ashes you
could drop anywhere right
i could drop ashes right now yeah i'll
drop ashley i'll just right now
so if i taught you if you're dead and i
wrap you in like you know and i wrap i i
put a weight on you like uh yeah 200
pound weight whatever it is and i throw
you over at the deepest part of the
ocean are you hitting the bottom of the
ocean floor before you're torn to shreds
oh yeah you are going to tame me to
shreds oh like a shark or something no
i'm sorry you know down there where
there's no light and those shits are
real weird down there yeah you know at
the bottom of the watch what's his name
the docks when they go like deep deep
deep like below submarines and stuff no
i mean yeah like i mean the bottom of
the deepest parts of the ocean where
there's creatures we don't even know
yeah they they there's no light
sometimes there's no light whatsoever
and they live down there they showed
like some pictures of them they look
like
they look like the things nightmares are
made of yeah you think that because how
far how how far is the deepest part of
the earth the marianas trench right is
like two miles two miles something crazy
so you would
we can't go down there because of the
pressure the mariana trench yeah so it
is how deep is it three thirty six
thousand two hundred feet deep so way
more than two months that's that's
that's like mountain smiles oh yeah and
you guys you guys know who's leading the
way on this right the guy who shot
jeffrey
a guy from titanic is like in that craft
from titanic
oh james cameron james cameron he go
he's he's the one that wants to be the
first guy because i don't think
everyone's ever
got down there already she got a full
documentary down there he went to the
bottom
the deepest part funded the production
of the equipment that could bring you
down there okay and it started during
titanic apparently so how how many feet
is it uh
how many feet in a mile it's like 5 239
or something or 5 000 something it's six
miles you were right right
two hundred and eighty so it's like
seven miles seven miles sometimes six
seven miles so if i tie a weight on you
i drop you down there are you getting
seven miles down before like something
comes and tears you to shreds yeah i was
gonna say seven miles is kind of long
look look at mount everest you could put
all of mount everest fully
mad with room to spare mad room mad room
son
so the largest mountain in the world is
underwater
is it yeah
i don't know what mountain it is but
it's the largest one is is underwater
large amount underwater yeah
yeah
m monochaea see it's it's 2 000 meters
bigger than mount everest
wow yeah
but it's just just just a little part of
it sticks up good
20 000 feet below the sea surface to the
sea floor
that's freaking wild man you ever think
about your uh
you're you're you're awake
and what who'll be there and what will
be said
yeah i always think like like when i
like if i died i wish i could see it
like when i would like when i make the
new york post you know what i mean would
they write an article right would they
say uh you know can we or would you be
like uh you know right like what do you
think you'd be big news oh you'd be huge
news
i think anyone like that's in the public
that dies will probably register
somewhere no but i mean you'd be like a
big like it'd be a big day
you think so if you want to i think so
right yeah of course like a huge thing
in new york yeah yeah you think like in
other places they wouldn't care really
like would they care in sri lanka
they're going wild
i think maybe in sri lanka maybe sri
lanka
yeah yeah a couple a couple of a couple
of days on twitter trending and that's
about it that's it no but hey listen but
what happens at the services though who
shows up who comes out of the woodwork
who speaks what do they say about you
what do you look like how you dressed
what i would do
i'd love to see what derozan would post
i want to get i would want to get buried
in a baseball uniform really dress me up
like the new york yankees pinstripe
one like a babe ruth yep like that yeah
yeah nice like yeah what about you what
would you want to go in sweatshirts
i'd say hoodie
i mean throw me in there in pajamas man
yeah i'm resting yeah right
i have an answer in a nice flannel
two-piece
pocket on the front you want that do you
want to get there with anything a phone
uh something laptop
yeah probably one of the one uh is a
figurine or something throw me in there
with the phone
go for bid
and then uh i don't know maybe some
photos i want to get buried with like a
you know a nice pizza pie that's nice
put it in there yeah you know give me
something right i have an aunt who she
tells i think i might have said this on
podcast before she like will bring it up
like at least once a year say hey
remember when i die take my shoes off if
you if you bury me with my shoes on in
the coffin i'll haunt you like that like
i don't know where she'll be cutting
like a piece what's her deal why does
she think that she's she's always had uh
pain in her feet you know she's always
had messed up feet so she said she
tasked me with this when i was about 10
years old that i must remember to take
her shoes off are you going to do it for
real
if i'm if if i die first yeah
if i die second yeah she dies first
you're really going to do it i will not
forget to do that it's been ingrained in
my hand but did she let anyone else in
the family know because then you're
gonna look at psychopath taking her
shoes off yeah and everyone's gonna be
like leave her alone and she's like she
needed this it's my it's it's
a little thing okay do you guys have any
requests for yours
um i think i want to party man yeah just
yeah can i sell ads celebrate money
i swear to god you own the documentary
rights of the funeral
you open up the casket it's just
manscaping i'm gonna force the
priesthood
going to force the priest to do
hellofresh
[Laughter]
this guy jesus diaz beto he got buried
sitting up like in his like he's yeah
yeah that's his funeral
that person
is in that photo he's wanted this on
purpose this is a list of people who
were dead outside the coffin at their
own face the thirteen strangest funerals
where the corpses attended their own
ceremony not in a coffin yeah he sat he
sat up with this no
yeah he's dead
oh my god yeah
this old black woman is she has a she
has a cigarette in her dead hands yes
and she's holding a glass she's drinking
a bush
beer in a wine glass yeah
may may burbank who died of cancer in
early june 2014 pictured seated at a
table at the charbonnet funeral home in
new orleans
wow she looks like she looks like like a
wax what do you call it madame tussauds
this is the way to do it we'll bring the
couch and the signage oh that's funny
if we die together we could just have if
we die together we'll just sit on the
couch just in the middle of a pond
all right who go who's next
there you go man
oh he's there too nothing in new orleans
is that the same funeral home charbonnet
wow do not want people looking down at
him
wow let's see mickey easterling another
new orleans
what is she doing
what's going on in new orleans i don't
know they believe in all that stuff
like that spiritual voodoo stuff
interesting
billy stanley no picture willie stokes
is hilarious
oh he's been shot oh my god got killed
on the steps of a motel no popped him up
in a driver's
into a cadillac they cut off the back
piece so he could sit up in it like a
car they put on a steering wheel which
by the way they could have done a better
job at that steering wheel yeah and then
they put wheels on the bottom of it this
is a dead man
driving a cadillac coffin yes
how does he go in the ground
dude i don't know his own mini cadillac
seville a thousand dollar bills
no
dressed for the occasion in a flaming
red suit he had several thousand dollar
bills sticking from his fingers i love
him wow what a waste of money
angel pontoya medina
this is like a fake tabloid like the
alien tabloids
okay this is where we go standing up
okay angel pandoya medina was shot down
in 2008 and thrown over a bridge in his
underwear is now forever remembered as
el muerto pareo or dead man standing his
corpse was leaning against the wall
dressed as a rapper and wearing his
favorite new york yankees cap he's
wearing sunglasses he's got chains on
his aunt's set all sorts came to see him
lawyers judges everyone was saying
things like for my week i want to be in
my recliner with a cup of coffee
he's standing in the corner like it's a
prank he's he's literally propped up
like he's he's like he's like one of
those knights in armor expressvpn
uh do you use it i do use it i use it as
well it keeps me in con
you know it's like i go incognito
because you don't want anybody knowing
what you they don't get your ip address
no i don't want you that's a safer way
to surf online i used to let people have
my ip address but now i respect myself
and no nobody has my ip address because
i respect who i am as a person i've
matured
i bought my i bought a year subscription
i have it on my laptop and my phone to
express vpn yes i do yes 100 pages too
every time you connect to expressvpn you
get a random ip address shared by many
other express expressvpn customers that
makes it harder and harder for people to
steal your to steal your stuff so but
you said you go into incognito mode this
is even more than that actually it turns
out that even in incognito mode in real
life your online activity still gets
tracked and data brokers still get to
use and to buy and sell your data right
that's what it is one of these data
points is your ip address data
harvesters use your ip to uniquely
identify you and your location but with
expressvpn your connection gets rerouted
through an encrypted server and your iep
address is masked i even got expressvpn
on my smart tv that's how crazy i got
with it so and i love it so if you
really want to go to incognito and
protect your privacy secure yourself
with the number one rated vpn visit
expressvpn.com hey babe and get three
extra months for free that's
expressvpn.com
slash hey babe e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash hey vape
let's talk about beam okay
beam organics babe i
uh i got my first beam about six months
ago and i i was having a little trouble
sleeping right okay i would toss and
turn the worst thing in the world is
when you go and like you're laying down
you know you have to get up the next day
and like halfway through the night
you're like [ __ ] i'm not falling asleep
i'm not falling asleep and then the next
day is completely shot that happened to
me for a string of days in a couple of
weeks and i was desperately looking for
a way to sleep better just so happens
they became a sponsor i got a sample
which i by the way i've re-upped twice
already on my own interesting and i got
their coco they're like hot cocoa powder
and i
healthy hot cocoa okay dream powder let
me tell you right now dude
it is
i and i told you this before it tastes
delicious and it's like a soothing cup
of cocoa before you go to bed and i
sleep through the night like nobody's
biz banged out i mean beautiful night's
sleep like dreams like rem
like that's me in the corner that's me
in the spotlight losing my religion rem
there it is yeah holy sh so it's really
that good because i you know like like
like we said we talked about they sent
it to you they didn't send it to me but
all i've heard from you yeah is that
it's like the best thing ever yeah
people need to know too like if you
don't know this some people think it's
like they come they confuse cbd and thc
but there's no thc in this like when i
first started doing it like uh i was i
was like does this have will i get high
from this that's not what cbd is
whatsoever there's no thc in it um
contains natural sleep promoting
ingredients it's triple lab tested uh i
didn't wake up feeling groggy or
anything like that i just had a really
good night's sleep uh here's why it
works our bodies have an endo
cannabinoid system or a highway of
communication between the brain and the
body specifically designed to work with
cannabi cannabinoids which is why cbd
cannabinoids have taken over the
wellness world recently
so
find out why forbes and new york times
are all talking about beam and it's why
it's trusted by the world's top athletes
like danica patrick and baker mayfield
well look at that look at that for a
limited time get twenty dollars off
seventy five dollars or more when you go
to bmorganics.com hey babe and use code
hey babe at checkout okay that's
b-e-a-m-organics.com
hey babe and use code hey babe for 20
off make 2022 the year of you with me
david
oh [ __ ] david morales is being he's
buried on a motorcycle doing what he
loves best he's involved and balm's
sitting on his beloved motorcycle but
he's in the racing position yeah he is
crouched down revving and his head is
that actually looks real
yeah that looks like how do they get him
to stay like that
they must have him glued
super glued to the seat i don't know is
that not weird though oh my god oh my
god
come on aromatic wait what's his name
paramedic
and edgardo
bombed in his ambulance uniform in the
ambulance he's sitting in the ambulance
let me ask you a question go scroll up
to the guy with the thing
is that for life is he embalmed for life
so he's going to be like basically like
a piece of um uh like when you have a
moose's head on the wall what's it's
called
taxidermy yeah he's basically like a
piece of taxidermy like like if that was
my loved one like like his aunt or his
wife or whatever she props him up in the
living room and then he just stays there
in that form forever well no i think
they probably bury him oh you do
yeah because once you embalm someone
embalming cannot completely halt the
natural process of decomposition in fact
it's against federal law to suggest that
embalming can completely stop
decomposition so you're committing crime
if you even suggest it and bombing is
one method funeral directors have to
ensure that human remains are able to be
interacted with by the public
you know um
i think maybe uh embalming could prevent
decomposition maybe
well i mean did i just
i was going to say do you say it again
and i'll call the police you're gonna
make a citizen's arrest i'll make a
citizen's arrest right now like i just
don't understand like after like a
couple of oh so they they don't stay
long
no i think just for the fume
but
then you're gonna buy that motorcycle
put him on the motorcycle just for a
couple hours oh i think well i think
maybe it was his motorcycle okay
i mean yeah this guy is dressed in full
boxing gear yeah christopher rivera
amora
standing in the ring gloves on and head
bad amore could have been preparing for
the fight of his life if he wasn't dead
oh jesus
yeah interesting well that i mean that's
pretty
you know now it's got me thinking like
you know what do you want to do pimp how
do you want to die
um
i don't i don't know how do i want to
die i don't know how do you want to be
buried is what i meant sorry i'll
definitely have it be a party
and no no ceremony it's boring do you
want to get buried with your equipment
with your sound equipment
uh now you can give it to delilah
let her film your funeral i want her to
start her own podcast torture you yeah
oh god she's gonna blow past me who do
you who do you think
all right did you have you guys made
your wills i just did for the first time
in my life yeah i did yeah yeah yeah
when you have kids you have when was
your first one when you i had to yeah
yeah but i have to i have to uh it is
weird though to even think about and
talk about but i have to it's also
because it's like so many permutations
so it's like all right i want to leave
something for these people this movie
and then there's all these things like
all right what if you die especially if
you have like a spouse that gets tricky
because like
if
that person dies before that person or
it's just very very weird there's all
these rules it was for me it was like
yours might have been pretty
straightforward i leave everything to my
daughter yeah well now two daughters now
so right like go back in and yeah that's
how they get you that's how they get
extra fees extra fees and you know
what's crazy is when you make a will or
light and to get life insurance you have
to like get like tested like blood work
blood pressure blah blah my guy who who
put it together for me was like you'll
you'll just get the you'll get the max
whatever it is like you'll get the top
level one because you're young healthy
whatever he calls and he goes hey he
goes after the blood work and the blood
pressure you're not gonna get the top
top level one right but you're gonna get
pretty close you get that too you didn't
get the top one i don't think i did no
yeah it's like it's that i don't get
that so they pretty much are like
evaluating your they're like you're not
you're based off our calculations you're
probably not going to live to like
that's great so you're an nft to them
they're like we actually you're a wild
card we don't know when you're gonna die
the original boring ap yeah
yeah that's what they said
remember when people used to call you
that
the boring how do you evaluate what you
even leave to people i don't even know
how i could it still it's just weird i
just look at everything i have and it's
like playing with monopoly it's just
like all right this person this person i
have a trust account that like and life
insurance that if i die before a certain
time with certain circumstances then the
trust is just goes into
goes all to my daughter when she's 18
and
before that it's run by like a like a
firm like a law firm you don't go into
cars or
properties
you you you do your possessions
anything notable like i i had to like
actually like say like note things that
will work like art or my sneakers or
something like that they they have a
value so i could if you don't put them
to someone you just put them to every
one person or you can like say this
person gets that i didn't really drill
down like that really even with ocd it
doesn't become like a
i got it it was it was hard for me i
started getting into percentages
and what percentages mean and like how
much i was leaving people with
percentages then tweaking the
percentages it's a tough comment i
wanted to get it over with soon because
like you don't want it that's a weird
country about your mortality so like i
just want to do it quick i was like
whatever just whatever just just give it
to somebody
that's so weird like you you want to
like be done with it
but it is weird you got to go back in
every time something changes too it's an
investment though like life insurance is
like a thing like if you can afford it
like you should have just because if
anything happens at least you know like
your loved ones are taken care of
and you guys have collected this on
other people
has anyone i never have no no like see
that's where i become like
well no well that's the thing like like
well that's the thing where it gets
weird like you know you know when a
spouse kills a husband or husband like
if there's taken out of life insurance
policies like oh you can get this much
money like i would only receive money on
life insurance if like
if like my mom or dad died and they had
a life insurance policy and left stuff
to me
like if i die my kids get money
you know what i mean but if i'm not
going to get anything
like if
i have to be in there like will you know
like if your grandpa dies
you could get money
like that's possible i've never gotten
anything from anything like that me
neither i never got anything
like zero so your will was probably
easier than mine
yeah mine was just straightforward it
was just my daughter at that point i
just had one kid i have like 20 people
in my will
yeah no see i just didn't want one kid
that's what i think they said it's gonna
change like it'll change like every four
years yeah you just keep thinking about
it and that yeah but it is a weird thing
you should have i have life insurance
you know i'll tell you what i'm going to
leave
my everything i have to one lucky
listener if they have the uh we're
playing the ryman
on march 11 11th international tennessee
and uh next night i'm in chattanooga and
if someone comes to the ryman with their
ticket stub yup i will pick someone at
random and they will become i'm not
gonna give him everything but i'll put
him in my will but you will be acting no
for real legally put in the will yeah
but you have to buy tickets to even
enter yeah so that's what it is and by
the way may 14th at the beacon
it's not on sale yet i don't think but
no it might be on sale i'm just saying
it in two weeks yeah it might be it
might be i think it would be listen to
me i'm playing the beacon theater i've
never played new york before in my life
this is the biggest show of my career
for real other than when i play with the
guys but my solo career solo career yeah
it's a special big to-do for me going to
be special guests it's gonna be a
special night and it might be on sale
right now i'm coming i would love you to
come actually no i can't i'm doing count
basie theater in new jersey that night
same night yeah damn it
rats rats damn i'm gonna come to yours
all right oh it happened already yeah my
beacon happened already it was all right
it's awesome it was great generation
standing ovation then we have a cash bar
after party in the basement that's right
fun time is that what you're doing yeah
why the hell not oh but for real yeah oh
you really are full full after party at
the beacon in downstairs they have a
private room oh absolutely amazing how
great is that yeah i don't do it
yeah i don't do that a lot uh but
the garden yeah radio you get a bracelet
on my list and then boom you're in okay
downstairs cash bar i love that yeah
they wouldn't let me buy it outside can
i just pay for the bottle so we can't do
that everyone goes down however many
people you want i think there's going to
be 55 people there okay go down with a
bracelet you all hung out down there
that's it private just for us yeah two
hours two hours that's it okay i'm gonna
try to get finger foods too okay why the
hell not which let me ask you a question
if you had a choice pigs in a blanket or
potato skins loaded
not even i would i actually don't even
have to use a a one of my trillions of
brain neurons firing i don't even have
to use one of them to tell you
immediately it's potato skins oh
yes thank you
i actually if i if pigs and blanket
became illegal
my life wouldn't change
one iota we had a heated debate on the
buds on taste buds and derosa took pigs
in a blanket i took potato skins i lost
it was pretty close though right it was
only like four percent loss but i lost
he won with [ __ ] cocktail weenies see
i would never i don't know who was
voting on that because because for me
potato skins i was nervous when you use
a big build-up
and that's by the way and that's taste
buds with joe derosa and sal volcano not
the taste buds and discovery plots
we're in a fight with discovery plus
right now yeah dominoes to tip customers
three dollars for placing pickup orders
as labor shortage continues wow that's
three dollars to come get your pizza i
kind of that's and for and listen i've
been there before i was i was there in
atlantic city if you're ordering
dominoes three dollars makes all the
difference
let me ask you a question is it three
dollars off the bill and this is a
marketing ploy uh or are they gonna give
you three three bucks as a tip
you know what i'm saying
or they're gonna give you three dollar
credit to order more dominoes yeah in
the form of a credits they can apply to
futures so it's basically just clever
marketing but i have to be completely
honest with you even though i'm a new
yorker i love italian food i love pizza
i domino's hits a spot
that's um
like it's i i i i would be sad if there
were no more dominoes yeah i could eat
dominoes like i can eat dominoes i
understand what you're saying so david
tell you this story one time i'm on the
road uh my lady's with me and uh i don't
know
we're in between days i don't know if i
had an off day something it was a [ __ ]
town i don't remember where and it was
rainy and everything we're going to a
movie right and so before the movie i'm
like there's no one around i'm like we
got to eat something most of the [ __ ]
was closed so we got went to domino's
right and we're going to order the pizza
and i'm just going to bring the pizza
into the movie theater why not so we we
order the pizza i walk in i'm waiting
for it there's only two young teenagers
working there just two young scrappy
dudes right and i say can i have like a
pepperoni pizza or whatever and i'm
watching the kid right
and he he's like yeah so we're staying
there i see him like put the cheese over
thing and he takes the pepperoni slice
and he goes
and he he whips it like he up like
almost like he's throwing down like full
house he just goes and he whips it on
the thing right and that's like that's
an odd way to put on a pepperoni right
and
i was like that's odd i didn't think
much of it
get the thing five ten minutes later get
the pizza pay him whatever we get in the
car go to the movie theater oh no maybe
we're gonna eat it right before the
movie so we open up i'll get traveled
with that open up the thing
it's the only pepperoni on it
it was dead in the center one pepperoni
dead in the center he must have been a
wise guy yeah just threw one i was like
that's a [ __ ] dude one pepperoni we
were crying laughing but it's like what
an [ __ ] like i i would have to drive
back 10 minutes like didn't he think i
would come back and be like hello like
what is this did you get cheesy sticks
dude did you get cheesy bread on the
side i don't remember yeah i don't i
don't remember but one pepperoni it was
the one he threw that's really really
really funny to turn out and because the
thing is when you eat dominoes too like
there's been plenty of times where i've
eaten dominoes and i've said oh my god
like this has taken years off my life i
spoke to a guy yesterday good friend of
mine i'm gonna see him tomorrow he told
me that for an entire year for one
entire year he didn't eat one vegetable
or drink one glass of water
that can't be real he said it was real
he said i didn't drink one glass of
water i have one vegetable for one
calendar year did he do that like
did he he like knew he was doing it yeah
or did he reflect back and go i don't
remember the last time i had a glasses
oh no he said i i i made a bet with
myself and my friends when i was like 25
years old he said it was like he said he
would drink like he would drink two
liter bottle of soda almost every day
he'd drink iced tea powerade gatorades
things like that but not one sip of
water like a cup of wood he's like you
know i got water when i brush my teeth
or water and food or got water in my
mouth in a shower but no i didn't drink
one glass of water have one vegetable
for one year and what was the result of
that 295 pounds
no now he weighs 210.
wow
219. what a dumb vet he was like i was
an idiot because i was just i was
complaining to him yesterday
just because i was like been drinking i
just feel awful about myself and my body
i'm like i feel like i've been so
disgusting i said i haven't i don't
think i've had a vegetable in a week i
said i've just been off the rails been
eating desserts and sweets and
disgusting and he was like a week it's
not you'll be back in a week i was like
no dude not at 37 he goes do you know
one time i didn't eat a vegetable or
drink one glass of water for a year so i
picked up the phone and called him
immediately i said explain
wow yeah and he said he would eat
dominoes pizza hut papa john's that was
huge for him he's like i would eat that
all the time he said he said by five six
months like i felt like it became a
thing where i was like i'm gonna i'm
gonna die like i'm just gonna kill
myself
he said he changed his brain chemistry
like he got like insanely depressed like
he went almost like suicidal towards
like the last six months of it but he
stuck it out he committed to that he won
that bet with his friends you should
have killed yourself
how's the ball drop just do you think
anyone ever did that blew their head off
on the countdown gotta be nine eight
seven and then just blew it off i bet
you it's every single year
i've never thought of it before right
but now that you're saying that there's
eight billion people
you don't think someone killed
themselves during the countdown for the
new year's eve ball drop how many people
just blow their brains out
january first oh my god deadliest day of
the year
what
how what
that's interesting
that's very interesting well you know
the the country with the most suicides
is norway which is you know that's where
peop frozen was made you think it's a
happy disney movie they're not they're
killing themselves left and right why
elsa killed herself why um because of
the darkness the six months of darkness
they get so why do they stay
i don't think they have anywhere to go
it's not it's listen it's expensive to
leave norway not many flights go there
the first day of the year average is 135
deaths second only to july 4th with 141
deaths unfortunately january 1st is also
the most deadly day for pedestrian
deaths as well according to this uh
i don't know pedestrians our good friend
of the show ryan hamilton
uh well wishes to you did you hear he
got hit by a box truck what ryan
hamilton got hit by a box truck what are
you talking about google ryan hamilton's
instagram ryan hampton by the way one of
the greatest comedians huge when did
this happen i i i i go to his instagram
or something like that yeah it's the
only show after getting is he okay
he's not i don't think so to be honest
when conscious see look whoa
i had to use and then look read the
thing sorry i have to say
move some upcoming shows as i was in an
accident i was hit as a pedestrian in a
crosswalk by a shuttle bus i have a
compound fracture
or arm that requires you know a compound
fracture it's a clean break right it
broke through skin too
like it's on clean break and it was
coming through okay uh i'm not able to
fly until cleared by my doctor
yes collapse uh uh seven seven broken
ribs and a punctured collapsed lung he
can't fly
uh so his shows are being postponed but
yeah ryan hamilton i mean it's it's like
it's an insane thing like you never know
he could have easily been killed got hit
by a shuttle bus in in new york city i
would imagine yeah holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah
i'm so grateful for her i didn't even
know about this i feel terrible
wow yeah he had to cancel all his big
shows but i understand sorry to my
grateful to my friends i know you may be
disappointed
i mean you imagine imagine somebody's
like you can't do the shows ryan really
yeah that's how he got hit by a bolt bus
[Laughter]
oh so well uh well wishes to ryan ryan
oh man sam let me know if you need
anything ryan if you listen to the
podcast and we know that you are yes
absolutely we'll bring you some soup
i'll bring you dominos
getting i saw i saw a kid get hit by a
car survive though but i saw him get
[ __ ] chillaxed by a car really yeah i
was in grade school
and what happened was a young kid yeah i
got like thrown over the car like like
you know car hit him and then he his
body rolled over and then he hit the
ground and got up like got up and limped
off and then sat i don't know if he's
like he had a head injury and then
collapsed later but like yeah no he was
wow yeah i was hit by a car
oh yeah that's right yeah i was four
playing frozen with my dad right station
wagon came into a parking lot that was
empty other than me and hit me i talked
about on this podcast i had to have
did you yeah i think i did maybe early
on but what happened again did you get
head trauma no
just got blasted i ran i woke up i was
knocked out and i woke up with my dad
and my dad's arms he's running
went to the hospital i don't really
remember much wow yeah i remember like
it happened when i was like man i was
young it happened when i was like four
yeah like five four whatever it was
right yeah and i remember i like i i
don't know what kind of a lawsuit this
is but i think i won
uh five thousand dollars
in the last he pops five votes no he's
in a thing i couldn't touch so i was 18.
did you touch it yeah i touched it when
i was 18 it was like 14 000 13 000. wow
so that's a lot of interest and what'd
you do with it yeah 14. uh you know i
don't really remember it i didn't blow
it like i was saving it for a while like
i was like you know but then i think i
just like added to it as i got older and
saved money that's like i have a family
member her dad died you know like and he
had you know gave like you know uh trust
not trust like you know whatever left
money you will
immediately got the money bought new
tits immediately
just use it all on boobs like like
immediately she was like 21 years old
stuff like that right you know my family
was like what are you doing wow just got
i mean immediate tits if you were a
female and you didn't like your breasts
would you get them would you get new
tits well i'm a male i don't like my
tits
and and and
truthfully even as a male there's breast
augmentation surgery i can get for my
like weird weirdly shaped pecs but i i
don't want to no i i've
as much as i as i as i uh uh have body
image issues and don't like what i see
all the time i would never even consider
plastic surgery only for aesthetic
reasons i would get it if i needed to
save my life right but i would never i
wouldn't i'm just like i'll just you
know i don't want to do that right i'm
like just because my thing is even if it
makes my body look better it might throw
off some type of like balance
homeostasis in my body that i don't like
my you know
jasmine has has fake has she has fake
boobs she hates them she's like i want
to get them out she's like i feel like i
did something to my body and my chest
and my heart my i don't i want them out
wow
it's depressing she's like and a lot of
women say that like they go with them
for five ten years like i want them out
i don't want them in my body anymore
it's not worth how it made me look and
feel so what is the process there i
think you just take them out like i
think you have to get another surgery to
open up your chest and then they get
removed but do you have your original
boob
yeah i guess you go but has it been
compromised by the show
but i think they have to probably do
some kind of lift maybe okay and maybe
they take fat from your butt or
something like that and put in your
boobs okay i don't know maybe they take
four guan fat
yeah maybe they do that's why they don't
what no no now we're ready
we're at like at 50 right now wow that
one flew by yeah
no one else is flying by the nfl season
tom brady yeah you know he won the super
bowl unbelievable i gotta give it up to
him seventh his seventh championship at
the age of 45 in the home city
which
and then i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention patrick mahomes
kansas city chiefs they got a good ball
club good ball club and then this year
the los angeles rams are in the super
bowl they're playing in their home city
against the cincinnati bengals yeah yes
you got matt stafford there and joe
burrows joe burroughs who looks like
homeless pimp joe burrow wears purple
glasses like the homeless pimp he was
talking after the game yesterday like
and i was looking at him he is so he's
very young right he looks like what a
quarterback like like a disney quarter
he does but he doesn't even have like
scruff no because he's like it was like
it was like baby face he hasn't hit
puberty yet that's wild yep he's yeah um
and by the way nick cannon did we say
nick cannon his eighth kid we talked
about that already yeah okay yeah yeah
so um
oh by the way real quick a couple of
weeks ago pimp was there with me i got
annihilated at gotham comedy club
although i'm not drinking august 26 at
gotham comedy club for pete alonzo's
charity pete alonso is a baseball player
for the new york mets one of probably
the best player in the team i mean smash
craig carton from like you know the
radio boomerang boom and carton were
there um i mean really really really fun
time then i went on the corner i've got
some common club to detroit pizza lions
tigers and squares i know it's
the four-slice pie it was yeah one of
the worst nights of my life vodka and a
pepperoni and i told homeless pimp that
it's because jasmine wanted one but she
did and i eat both of them
you ate two detroit pizzas yeah
it's good pizza yeah but but you know
what i'm saying like but i'm abusing
myself a little bit now wow it becomes
abuse and you got you were drinking were
you drunk on stage you did it was i
drunk on stage pimp
um we were a little bit lit up i bought
a few remember we had a few rounds we
had a few rounds before you were
performing and nobody else no it was i
was one of four comics okay yeah well
there was one guy who went on i forgot
what his name was but he was supposed to
do 10 minutes he did about four minutes
was bombing and just said good night in
the middle of the joke no way i was on
the floor laughing wait you didn't know
the other guy went on and did comedy no
he didn't swear to god he sat on the
stool and started telling stories about
baseball and about god and stuff like
that and then just got off she said like
let's go medicine goddess adrian i
baluchi went on and was
doing some of the funniest [ __ ] i've
ever seen she ended her set with saying
i'm a yankees fan and got booed off
stage and was dying laughing with the
comic she was in my opinion the set of
the night oh my god somebody heckled her
and she pointed her fingers and said i
wish this was a gun yeah no no no
if you guys don't know adrian and i
pollucci look her up her comedy stand up
is i think personally one of the best
joke writers dark it's great she's great
she was on the cruise with us actually i
just i know yeah she was yeah she just
um i just took a long ride with her when
we got snowed in in cleveland we drove
to detroit overnight so you wouldn't get
snowed in there and i rented a car and
and it was me veda ahri and adrian did
you bring it open for you
she was with ari i was there with veda
she was there with ari and we both
didn't want to get stoned in my buddy
chris johnson and so i mean you know
and then we just drove but we had like a
i think it was like a five-hour car ride
in the snowstorm
and it was through an active snowstorm
through the entire time like we went we
didn't go above 37 miles an hour we saw
cars sliding off the road we just played
we hydro played a few times we just did
it we just went real slow and we did it
because
it was a blizzard in cleveland and we
didn't want to get snowed in we wanted
to get home didn't it was it did it turn
out to be a good move if you would have
stayed in cleveland you would have so
every
single flight every
single flight got cancelled except for
monteneries
in detroit no no no in cleveland oh so
if you would have just stayed in
cleveland your flight would when i'm
when i'm telling you i'm not
exaggerating a hundred percent of the
flights
besides our two flights did not get
canceled i got postponed a little it
must be that must be funny though like
we laughed we said you know what the
five hour we were crying laughing in the
five at the five-hour car ride
about this i was on a jet blue flight
the other from l.a to new york okay i
was in jetblue flight the plane was so
off balance because there were so few
people in there that people who were
sitting like in row 47 got to sit and
mint just for the balance of the flight
and they said you know the pilot said
we're really supposed to ask you to go
back to your seat after that because
it's meant they said but we'll just you
guys can stay in those seats wow how
crazy is that i've never in my life seen
that did you get to go yeah i was in
mint okay yeah mint by the way
if you're gonna fly
first class opportunity from l.a to new
york or new york to la i don't care if
other airlines even want to sue me i'll
say
i'll say
passionately number one i'll say because
i'm just feeling this way i'll say that
you um embalming fluid does not
necessarily mean that your body won't
decompose i'm just gonna say it's a
crime sue me
second
fly jet blue mint i know there's other
airlines that have better this or that
jet blue mint is the best first class
experience they know what they're doing
ever yeah you the best food the best
options the best the most comfortable
seats the best flight attendant the best
everything clearing away jet blue mint
is the absolute way to go i agree in
jetblue if you're watching and we know
that you are we fly you from i'm a
mosaic member of my friends
yes and i really like it they give you a
real menu real utensils you could choose
the food if you want yes by the way the
reason i ended up doing it is because i
never used to fly first class then when
they came out it was same half the price
it was more affordable than every other
first class no no no no and i was like
wait that's a first class seat and
they're like yeah i'm like that is less
than half the price that's the only
reason i do too jet blue mint from new
york from la to new york was 980 and i
bought it because the delta comfort was
eleven hundred dollars from la to new
york so right i'll just spend 200 less
and fly first class right right why the
hell not exactly i mean even 980 some
people like that's too much for it
but when it first came out when it first
came out it was five six hundred dollars
really i swear well i mean listen five
six hundred dollars in 980 is not too
big i mean 300 is but it's double it 600
bucks for a first class round-trip round
trip yeah
i did i didn't fly first class on the
way out there i just did it on the way
back the seats have a massage function
they were the best there are tons of
outlets yeah you get
the full bottles of water there's
storage i'm also the screens are that
big it's free wi-fi wi-fi
delta does a nice one too but yeah first
class is first class whatever but the
jetblue mint i mean it's just it's mint
it's just the and i used to be a big guy
flying on the red eye i used to be loved
the red-eye but then i realized i'm so
exhausted the next day i'm done with
that now i go i mean i'll i'll sacrifice
the day i'll leave la at one o'clock two
o'clock and land in new york at 10 11.
yeah just because
literally my next day is real i can't
function you can't come back you you
come back early but then you you can't
do anything no yeah and you don't really
see it's only it's six hours to get from
new york to la four hours to get from
l.a to new york they're flying yeah yeah
so i'm like i can't do it i know and
then by the time you get home you're
done
done yeah i agree what else has done
this podcast that's right
just spin hey baby
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe